Mike plans to build a porch
with the floor plan below.
In order for the porch to be
up to city code, it cannot
have a perimeter that is
greater than 300 feet.
Let me underline that.
It cannot have a perimeter that
is greater than 300 feet.
Or another way to think about
it, the perimeter has to be
300 feet or less.
Find the perimeter of the porch
using the floor plan
below and determine whether or
not its perimeter meets the
city's code requirements.
All right, so we need to find
the perimeter of this porch,
and just as a reminder, the
perimeter is the distance
around the object.
Or another way of thinking about
it, it's the sum of the
lengths of the sides
of the object.
So to find the perimeter of this
porch, we just have to
add up these lengths of
the different sides.
So let's do that.
So we're going to add up 40 plus
20 plus 55 plus 30 plus
95 plus 50, and we're adding,
just to make sure we know what
we're doing.
We make sure we've aligned
them by place,
which we've done here.
The ones places are
all aligned.
The tens places are
So now let's start on
the ones place.
What is 0 plus 0 plus 5
plus 0 plus 5 plus 0?
Well, that's really just the
same thing as 5 plus 5, which
is 10, right?
The 0, carry the 1, or another
way of thinking about it,
regroup the 1, which is
really a 10, right?
It's 10.
The 1 in the tens place
literally represents 10, so we
put it in the tens place,
and now we add up
all of the tens places.
So we have 1 plus 4 is 5, plus
2 is 7, plus 5 is 12, plus 3
is 15, plus 9 is 24,
plus 5 is 29.
So the total perimeter of Mike's
porch here is 290 feet,
which is less than 300 feet,
so it meets the city code.
It could have even been equal to
300 feet, so we could have
even said it just has to be
less than or equal to 300
feet, and we meet
our city code.
So he can go ahead and
build this porch.